hello everyone and welcome to round six
of the 1972 World Chess Championship
match between Robert James Fischer and
Boris Casa de beat Spassky
and now if you remember in game 5
Spassky allowed Fischer to immediately
go for the nimzo-indian defense and he
was really up for a big fight he tried
it to create a chance he tried to create
chances for the entire game but Fischer
equalized very early in the game and in
the end it was actually Fischer who won
that game and it was a very important
game to win as it equalized the match
it's two and a half points each this is
game 6 and everyone thought that this
game would have a huge toll on Spassky
Fischer as we already said celebrated in
the pool and Spassky he wasn't sad or
alone in his room or anything he was a
as usual just playing ping-pong with his
second his international master friend
even a from Estonia and the fans from
Iceland did the children were returning
balls as you know they were playing
ping-pong and Spassky always thanked
them afterwards so it's not like
anything was different than usual even
though now the match was equalized so
this is game 6 and it's very interesting
for I forgot to mention this during Game
five during Game five a million I drove
arrived he had a flight from Buenos
Aires and everyone said that if if me
gone I'd have arrived all the way from
Buenos Aires then surely the match will
continue and Fischer will not bail on
the match because it's a very expensive
flight and the night off would not risk
it so there we have it and also a
neither of you know offered us some
insights the how fishery managers to so
easily convert such tiny advantages he
said night off said that Fischer doesn't
think of chess as most of them do
because Fisher has all of all of these
positions all of these positions from
games that were played so long ago and
Fischer doesn't study how to win a
certain position rather Fischer is more
interested how a player lost a certain
position which move was crucial for him
losing that game and Fischer memorizes
these losing moves that convert a
holdable position into a losing position
and it's very very difficult to surprise
Fisher to enter such a position that
will not be hold about as possibly had
such a chance in game four would that
work the DHD h8 maneuver but he missed
it and now it's a totally a different
match it's okay
Game six and here as the quote says
above the board expect closed openings
from Fischer something Viktor Korchnoi
often said during a spassky's
preparation in training camp but
everyone was like nah and even the
newspapers they were often depicting
this whole match situation were always
the drawing of Fischer and Spassky was
with the Fischer pushing efore with the
white pieces and there were even jokes
like but Boris what he what if he
doesn't play E 4 and this Spassky always
responded I'll just play the tartakower
variation I mean I've never lost the
game with the black pieces in that
variation what can Fisher possibly used
to surprise me there but as Intel bought
Vinick game Game six game six pressure
versus Spassky will also bring some very
nice ideas so let's check it out
I like the quote above the board's we
just indeed in this game Fischer does
play see four and it's not the first
time in his life ever played c4 in a
tournament he did use it against polo
gear skin the palma de mallorca 1970
inter-zonal tournament the they drew
that game and also he tried it in the
last game of the palma de mallorca intra
zonal in 1970 against Oscar panel but
panel resigned the game without even
playing it's ok he 6 by Spassky Knight
to f3 d5
we have d4 by Fischer so we entered the
Queens gambit the client and although
it's not the first time pressure plate
c4 this is the first time in fresher
plays the Queens gambit declined with
the white pieces in his entire career so
like we said well Spassky do what he
said he would do if Fischer indeed
doesn't open would be four so let's see
Knight to f6
we have Knight to c3 back up to e7 this
is all standard theory of the Queens
gambit declined butter up to g5 with
castles III h6 kickin the bishop back
Bishop to h4 and now B
six we have the tartakower variation and
indeed Spassky does does what he said he
would do seek after Sun d5 Knight
captures on d5 Bishop captures on e7
Queen captures on e7 and the knight
capture Sun d5 with he captures on d5
and now look to see one this is a
well-known position of the turtle cover
so nothing out of the ordinary here as
Spassky develops the Bishop to e6 Bishop
to e6 you could also develop it to
develop it to b7 but it's it was kind of
known that at some point c5 will be
played and then if captures captures
then the B file could become open and
then the bishop might be somewhat
vulnerable so instead if he develops at
the e6 we have Queen to a4 also there
was a well-known move c5 by Spassky and
now comes this Queen to a3 simply piling
up on the c5 pawn and also pinning it
you cannot push c4 this would be
excellent if you could but you can't
because the Queen 97 is undefended rook
to c8 adding more defense to the ca a c5
pawn and here comes the Bishop to b5 and
excellent move by Fischer which kinda
makes it hard for Spassky to develop his
pieces you can't really develop the
knight if you develop it the d7 that's
kind of the whole point of the Bishop to
b5 move if you develop a bit the d7
Fischer will simply grab it play bunch
of captures Knight and d7 you will lose
the defender of the c5 pawn the Queen
will be misplaced and then you will be
able to capture on c5 so this is the
idea but is this Fischer's idea is this
a novelty in fact it's not and it's
interesting
once again Fischer plays a variation
that was played in the 1970 in the
Soviet Team Championship between a
Semyon Foreman and none other than f'ing
Geller so it's like Fischer purposely
plays variations that at some point a
finger are found himself in and it's
like it's like Fisher knows that Spassky
will not remember what Geller told
Spassky so okay very interesting we have
a success Baskin wants to kick away this
Bishop and it's not all that easy to get
rid of this Bishop for example if you
try something like Bishop to d7 Fischer
will simply go back Bishop to e2 and you
still can to develop
tonight because now the bishop is
covering this square and of course you
don't want to play the c7 because you
have to keep an eye on the c5 pawn and
if you tried it to repeat moves then you
will lose a temple because now Fischer
has already developed the bishop so
instead after this Bishop to b5 moved a
sex by Spassky and it's not really an
attacking move since the pawn cannot
capture the bishop just yet as the rook
on a8 is undefended the rooks are not
connected just yet so KD captures on c5
by Fischer and here we have B captures
on c5 if you play rook captures on c5
it's not all that impressive Fischer can
just castle you still can't capture here
because the Queen is undefended and you
still can't capture here because the
rook is undefended so be captures on c5
we have castles by Fischer and now comes
rope to a7 and this is the problem this
is the same move effing Geller played
against Foreman in the 1970 Soviet team
championship and after that game not
immediately but sometimes during the
1970 he mentioned this to Spassky and he
said that instead of this rook to a7
move I could have equalized quite easily
with Queen - b7 our following up with
Queen to b6 and head Spassky remembered
this he surely would have played it but
Spassky doesn't remember it and he
simply repeats what Geller played
against fulmen in 1970 which is rook to
a7 now the rook is defended and at some
points surely a capture son b5 can be
played so further simply moves the
bishop but we have Bishop to e2 and now
comes Knight to d7 you have to develop
it but there's a really no good way not
to do it here you allow this Knights to
d4 move because now your rook is
unprotected on c8 but even if you tried
some other way of dealing with this for
example a5 it doesn't really matter
rook the c3 a Fischer would simply
threaten to double up rooks on the C
file and at some point you would still
have to develop the knight and now after
rope the c1 Queen to d8 on pinning but
now Bishop to b5 and we get a very
similar position to what happened in the
footman versus girl game in 1970 the
night is getting eliminated and the
of the c5 pawn will be lost or or c4
will be played but in any chance this is
what happened in the foreman versus
versus geller so tonight's the d7
immediately by Spassky we have Knights
to d4 now you cannot capture the knight
of course because the rook is undefended
on c8 we have Queen to f8 and here it's
it's a nice idea because the queen is
now guarded but now it allows Fischer to
simplify into a better position Knight
captures on e6f captures on e6 and now
you could play something like Bishop to
g4 which is of course possible simply
trying to pile up on this pawn but Queen
to e7 defends it and black is perfectly
fine here so instead Fischer plays a
much better move because of black if you
look at the black looks at the broken a7
isn't all that impressive
okay the rookin see it is very nice the
knight really still has to find what to
do with the night and one thing black
does have going for himself is a very
nice pawn center
so if black can stabilize this black
should be fine so further immediately
attacks it he pushes efore and now you
really have to decide what to do here do
you push this pandu push this pawn do
capture here because with this maneuver
if you capture then simply rook the c4
you're gonna double up rooks on the C
file you're gonna win the c5 pawn the
double D pawns are very weak you're
gonna win them eventually so it's a it's
a much better position for black as
possibly isn't interested in this so in
this position
Spassky actually pushed d4 and here we
have a moment both unique mentions this
that this is the crucial moment in the
game that up to here okay you didn't
play the improvement Geller mentioned to
that going to be 7 to b6 maneuver but
here you should have played c4 c4
immediately offers a trade of Queens and
ok Botvinnik mentions that after Queen
to h3 going after the e6 pawn Queen to
f7 defending you could try Bishop to
Bishop to h5 to dislodge the Queen or
bait the g6 but the
Quinn will ignore you so rush up to G
for botanique mentions rook to e8
defending these exponents now captures
captures and here rook F to e1 rook
captures rook rook captures anyone and
now since it's a direct translation from
Russian of the Nikolaj crow Buell's book
in the translation and chess comm there
is it says like botanique said King to
f8 what came to f8 of course doesn't
work but feel free to pause the video
here and find how white would win in
this hypothetical situation it's a it's
a very nice little combo I'll give you a
couple of seconds to decide whether you
want to do it for those of you who are
able to do it congratulations you are an
excellent solver of hypothetical
situations and for those of you just
want to enjoy the show it's actually
Queen back to a3 check the rope is
covering the file so you do have to move
the kink once you move the King Bishop
d6 simply wins the Queen but I'm sure
it's a wrong translation that the idea
is not linked to a fade but rather night
to a fate simply guarding a d6 square
the person who translated it probably
just wrote K for a night but K is a king
n is a knight a but still I thought it
was a very funny
but yeah the botanique says that white
is better here but still white would
have to really really prove that he is a
much better player to actually put this
for a win but instead after E for
Spassky pushes d4 and okay we have f4
now here Fischer for once increases his
control of d5 square not allowing Knight
to e5 not allowing this pond to be
pushed 3/5 but one other thing that is
now possible the queen is now coming to
h3 and this Bishop is coming to c4 to
pile up on this e six pawn so okay Queen
to e7 mmm you have to move the Queen off
of off of the F file and now Fischer
pushes 'if I've an even stronger grip on
the position now the f6 square is taken
away from the knight so what do you do
here rook to b8 as pasca tries to create
some chances along the semi open B file
Bishop to c4
simply continues with this plan of
piling up on the e6 pawn and here we
have King to h8 as fast it doesn't want
to keep your skin on this diagonal
because f5 is definitely coming for
example if you try to defend night to a
fate to bring a defender of d6 pawn this
way alright f5 is coming and now there's
really nothing to do f6 is coming next
and black is completely getting
destroyed here so okay after this Bishop
to c4 supposed to place King to h8 and
now we have Queen to h3 s plants simply
piling up on d6 pawn now you don't
really gain anything by capturing the B
to pawn it's a pretty useless pawn white
will simply grab the central pawn and
create a pasty porn so here knife to f8
simply defending here and here fish are
simply improves b3 Spassky pushes a5
hoping to get a foreign at some point
and here Fischer says okay now it's
enough I have a light square Bishop you
have so many light square weaknesses
it's time to break through here Fischer
pushes f5 and okay we have a captures on
f5 rook captures on f5 now and then out
Knights to h7 hoping to either get nice
to g5 in and it seems like you know when
your opponent plays a move like this you
might think okay my opponent just
totally gave up he's just playing
nonsense moves but it's actually a very
poisonous move for example you think
that okay I have a bishop on c4
controlling f7 I could simply play rook
to f7 the Queen has to move I'm gonna
win this rook on a 7 but this would
actually be a huge mistake as now you're
losing the game as White Knight to g5
wins the game here after you capture the
Queen black captures your queen with
check you have to capture the night and
then rook captures black is up the
exchange and winning this game so you
know even though it doesn't matter how
good your position is you always have to
be careful of such tricky moves but and
okay Fischer simply doubles up rooks
rook C to F 1 and now comes to Queen
Queen to d8
here Spassky doesn't want his Queen to
be available for this Queen to f7
maneuver and also to introduce more
defenders to to the back rank and also
to perhaps at some point start pushing
his don't pass the
porn queen to g3 by Fischer and
excellent move that is preparing a lot
of a lot of mating ideas also at some
point this point will be pushed to e6
and Queen to e5 this beautiful
centralizing move is definitely in the
preparation rook to e7 by Spassky you
have to try and activate your pieces
that this is this is passkeys idea
h4 by Fischer simply not allowing this
knight to come to g5 is if Spassky
instead of rook to e7 tried Knight to g5
then h4 would just kick the knight
Knight back night to h7 and now look to
f7 there's really nothing to do here ro
captures rook captures there is the
threat of checkmate on g7 so there's
really nothing to do other than Queen to
g8 and now e6 is coming with the threats
of rook captures and Queen captures on
b8 once you move the rook for example
rook e8 e 7 is coming and now there's
really nothing to do Rocky 8 rook is
coming to f1 and the queen is lost so
after Queen to g3 rookie 7 instead of
Knight g5 but simply h4 Fischer improves
the position rook beat the b7
introducing another defender of the g7
pawn but now comes c6 also a very nice
idea now now the f6 square does seem to
be available for the night but everyone
knows that once this night comes here
that Fischer is just gonna gobble it up
rook beat the c7 as now after East 6 the
c5 pawn was under attack so sparsely
simply defends it Queen to e5 as planned
Fischer places his queen on this
beautiful central it's square Queen to
e8 but what else is there if you if you
try to pull the pawn it doesn't work
simply rook to f3
the point is attacked twice once you
push to d2 roof comes to d3 attack the
Queen once you move the Queen simply
grab on d2 there's there's no way to
take advantage of the past pawn after
Queen e5 we have Queen to e8 and now
comes a 4 with this a for a move Fischer
puts Spassky in sort of a tube swung and
you do have to play something you can't
play the rook all of the squares for the
rook are not available do
to the pawn this rook has to keep an eye
on this c5 pawn you know that if you
play the knight filter just gonna gobble
it up so there's really nothing to do
here Spassky has to wait and see what
Fischer will do Fischer simply plays
rook to f2 probably looking for a
breakthrough we have Queen back to e8
and now look back to f3 we have Queen
back to d8 now the the d3 Square is
covered twice but now Fischer simply
goes all-in as everything is set rush up
to d3 now you can see that the queen is
coming to e4 and the bishop queen batter
will be very unpleasant along this
diagonal Queen to e8 still Spassky
doesn't really have any moves and then
out comes Queen to e4 and now you can
see that if this rook was gone you would
simply have Queen captures on h7
checkmate so there are a lot of nasty
discoveries here and you have to move
the knight Knight to f6 is played but
now comes rogue captures on f6 we have G
captures on f6 and now comes Rock
captures on f6 so what do you do here
there are so many threats here for White
King to g8 is played not allowing the
rook to capture on h6 with check and
here a lot of moves are winning for
example you could simply capture on h6
and go from there
but like in more amorphous the Opera
House game this would be a butcher's
move and Fischer like Morpheus an artist
and he does not use butchers moves so
Bishop to c4 and here there really is no
move to play the the threat is rook to
f7 for example if you play a waiting
move such as rook to e7 rope to f7 wins
the game there is no defense against
Queen to h7 checkmate if you capture
here then pawn captures will of course
cost you a queen Queen captures and now
even Queen g6 check you can't capture
because of the pin I would have to move
King f8 and now captures captures and
captures which check o Queen against the
rook easily winning so after Bishop to
c4 as possible try to cling to a trait
but now Fischer simply played Queen to
f4 and now there is really nothing to do
here there are so many winning moves
here but the most obvious one is rook to
f8 and there is there is no move that
defend against rook to a fate black
simply loses a queen and after that
checkmate will follow so this is a hand
move 41 it was in this position that
world champion Boris Spassky resigned
the game Fischer won Game six and in
this moment a Fisher took the lead in
the match the result is now three and a
half to two and a half in Fischer's
favor so not only did I first win such a
beautiful game but for the first time in
this match Fischer takes the lead and
now this surely will take a pretty huge
toll on Spassky I've a lot of you have
been mentioning this in the comments yes
I've seen the movie pawn sacrifice with
Tobey Maguire and yes this is the moment
where thousands of people were
applauding Fischer for his beautiful
positional play and with them Spassky
also stood up and spicy also started
applauding Fischer official later said
that this was simply too much to take
because he considered Spassky an
adversary and that this moment truly
touched him and that he had to leave
immediately that he couldn't he couldn't
watch Spassky applauding him so a very
nice moment for history and for chess I
really do hope you enjoyed it and later
Spassky said that Fischer he said that
he was a very feverish and impulsive
perhaps the pressure before the match
and in the first games took its toll but
I want to give Fischer credit as well
his win in the sixth game was very good
so even praises along with applause from
the world champion so yeah really really
amazing stuff here I mean I really
really had a lot of fun preparing this
game using the book by using the diary
by Nikolai Crow gives using all of the
available materials using the interview
with Anatoly Karpov
I read the two books I already mentioned
by adding material it's one under Bobby
Fischer on the move one no it's my
friend Bobby Fischer the other one is
Boris Spassky on the move so a lot of
very very useful information a lot of
vast knowledge in this but every
I revisit this this whole match I always
find out something more and increased my
own vast knowledge so that's a game six
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank a sama lab chee cheong ho Ryan
McKnight Ralph vida and Felix cluster
Meier for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
most likely continuing the Fisher series
with Game seven of this historic match
thank you all and I'll see you soon